from monday hospitality will be able to
open
indoors the rest of our tourism industry
will be able to
reopen uh indoor events
will begin again for a limited number of
people
cinemas theaters concert halls will
begin the journey to
resuming and because the number of
people suffering from coronavirus in
wales continues to
go down then we're able to slightly
increase the number of people
able to be together in a purple
restaurant or cafe
from four as we'd originally anticipated
to six
and how rigidly will you stick to your
lockdown
exit plan bearing in mind the indian
variant
of coronavirus how how much will you be
monitoring that and how much will it
affect
your plans well it's already affected
our plans in the sense that we had
considered some further easements as
from
monday and have decided to hold back on
those for the moment
until we see the advice from sage which
met yesterday on our own scientific
advisors
which we expect imminently there were 17
cases of the indian variant in wales
yesterday but over 700 in england
and there's a concentration of those in
the northwest of england and
the border between the northeast of
wales and the northwest of england is
very porous
so we've decided just to pause wait to
see
just how significant the spread of the
indian variant is
and then we'll continue to take
decisions in the careful step-by-step
way we have throughout the pandemic
not wanting to put at risk the very good
position we are
in in wales today the lowest levels of
coronavirus anywhere in the united
kingdom
and the highest levels of vaccination uh
you said that you've held back
on easing various restrictions
specifically what what did you have in
mind
and what impact has the indian variant
had on you
uh well we had thought of moving ahead
with the reopening of
smaller events we'll pause that for a
moment
we were thinking of liberalizing the
rules in the way in which people
can uh meet together not just in their
extended household but beyond that we'll
pause that for the moment if the advice
on the indian variant
is uh that it is safe to move ahead we
won't need to wait for
the end of our next three week cycle to
do those things
but the indian variant is giving us
pause for
concern we don't know enough about
whether it is more transmissible than
the kent variant
we don't know enough about whether the
vaccination program
is as effective in dealing with it as it
is with other variants we have
in wales and until we're a bit clearer
on that
i think it is sensible to take a
precautionary approach
wait for the evidence and then make the
decisions
when we have a better sense of what we
might be up against
the uh welsh vaccination has been the
most successful in
in the uk if uh levels of
coronavirus increase across the border
will you then look at restrictions on
travel
not expecting to do that uh at the
moment
uh i i've heard uh you know english
ministers saying that they may
think of amending their vaccination
schedule we would look at that
too but we're in the fortunate position
in wales that in terms of second doses
over 90 percent of all 70 year olds
all 80 year olds all clear home
residents have already received the
second dose of the vaccine in wales and
we've got pretty good second dose
numbers of people
further down the age ranges as well so
we'll be keeping the vaccination program
under review in case we need to modify
it
in the face of the indian variant but
we'll be doing so
from a pretty successful platform
uh now in terms of uh domestic and
political reshuffling you've had a
reshuffle of your cabinet and you've
moved
vaughn getting away from health minister
um why was that and it's a bit of odd
timing considering we are still in the
pandemic and by all accounts
he was doing a great job uh well he said
he was doing a
very good job of course you must
remember that in wales we're a small
government
and a small cabinet so vaughn has not
disappeared at all he's
gone to take on the very significant
responsibilities
of helping us to rebuild our economy as
we come out of coronavirus
but whenever our cabinet will be
discussing uh
the impact of uh the pandemic he'll be
there with all the experience he's had
and all the advice he will be able to
bring
we're fortunate that our new health
minister elenid morgan
was already in our cabinet with
significant health responsibilities
so she comes to that job very well
prepared
uh our hope is of course that we are
putting coronavirus behind us
and the focus of my new cabinet
will be on rebuilding wales rebuilding
our health service rebuilding our
economy
dealing with that other great crisis of
our time in climate change
as we move beyond the crisis that has
gripped us for the last 15 months
uh you've repeatedly said that you'd
step down as first minister and uh
labour leader in this uh senate term is
that something you're still
planning on doing uh well my focus is on
making sure that we complete the job
uh of getting wales beyond coronavirus
and then setting us on that
ambitious path which my party set out in
our election manifesto
uh and the time will come before the end
of the seventh term when it will be
right to hand over to somebody
will be here beyond the next five years
uh but all my energies and all my
efforts are focused not on that
uh but on what happens over the next two
or three years
crucial years for wales putting the
pandemic behind us
putting us on the path to the future
creating that
agreement from wales mark drakeford fest
minister of welsh thank you very much
for speaking to us this morning
thank you